je voulais juste savoir si vous
m'entendez bien comment vous allez ce
soir et comment vous aborder ces quinze
derniers jours de campagne en ayant le
qu'ovide
écouter aujourd'hui tout va à peu près
bien sauf que je m'entends en écho dans
votre dans mon oreille et que votre
caméra mal est en train de téléphoner
donc c'est très très compliqué pour
faire l'interview pour moi ce sont pas
pensées positives perpétuelle les 3 p
c'est ma devise je suis d'accord
positive et les trois p moi je connais
les 3,6 mais d'être pris pour satan des
toilettes et étoilé de royal l'asile à
ce soir le trône on va savourer ah ouais
la mode est bien la seule étoile et et
la douche raoult et j'ai pensé
à toi lecture que c'est la base de faux
travail les crises assez comme ça mon
gars et c'est parti un mais bon moi je
moi je crois d'une douche pour les turcs
toilettes turques ça va c'est pas un
trop on est content c'est pas un trop
mais ya pas de chasse d'eau est ce que
je peux vous faire toucher la chose la
plus douce à portée de main ici sur ce
plateau
mois peut-être lé ces essais mais
c'était tout public c'est au public ce
sont les mains de pierre
c'est la chose la plus douce fond noir
au malawi
[Musique]
incroyable mais
jamais un travail manuel en 76 ans ces
dernières questions fabien au seul chez
vous faites la vaisselle
bien sûr non parce que je vous dis ça
parce que vous voulez créer une question
parce que je vous demande si vous faites
la vaisselle à
faire ou rien je ne sais même pas
changer une ampoule vous savez même pas
faire réchauffer un plat nord cuisinella
jeu pendant pendant le conflit qu'avant
dans le confinement pendant le
confinement j'ai appelé
pour lui dire combien de temps ça
d'émettre des pâtes oui ça le truc là
dans la salle que sur le quoi et je lui
ai demandé combien de temps ça dure
[Musique]
même avant
c'est un peu
choisir un
ou changeriez coin alors 20 ans de moins
et 20 centimètres de plus aux jambes ce
qui m'évite on voit mon actif
leblanc 7 va super bien tu veut dépenser
1 marine landrot là là tout de suite la
récitation la récitation de marilyn
monroe bien bien bien le prochain
candidat et fils de berger il s'est
engagé très tôt en politique longtemps
proche de françois même passer devant la
caméra tout va bien tanguay
a tellement puissante et interviews
auprès pose des questions de fou quoi
c'est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'on a on n'a pas ce niveau-là
d'interviewer en france donc moi je
préfère aller du côté de l'atlantique
tu m'écoutes opa
soit une écoute son attention de temps
et je suis détendu en fait benon pardon
là vous n'avez pas l'air détendu un jour
là
bas on sait pas thomas qu'est ce qui
vous prend tout à coup je déteste c'est
qu'on me coupe la parole quand je parle
ça ne se fait pas c'est un manque
d'éducation m a fait monter le sang
chaud et à montrer faut arrêter je
trouve toujours qu'en france on a un peu
tu vois aux etats unis c'est plus
mais non quand on reçoit des acteurs
américains on se dit qu'ils sont
tellement plus pro tellement plus
généraux est tellement plus drôle que
les acteurs et humoristes français ma
maison c'est exactement la même chose